oh yeah here we go Happy New Year happy
2017 first podcast of two zero one seven
for those of you that don't know what
that means that's 2017 you're on the
Harlan Highway I'm Harlan Williams so
excited to have you here today we're
gonna talk about the new year I'm gonna
give you some homework for the new year
right out of the gate where do you hear
this I'm gonna be like a taskmaster
today but hopefully it's all for for the
sake of doing good for yourselves and
for the world also some really fun crank
calls today we're gonna call a sex shop
and get a little naughty we're gonna go
I'm gonna go into Rogers sound booth and
we're gonna take some calls in there and
mess around with people calling to Roger
and then as you know sadly George
Michael passed away on Christmas Day
and we were able to get our hands on Boy
George another 80s pop icon rock star
and Boy George is gonna call in and
share his thoughts on the passing of his
pal George Michael very very sad
hopefully Boy George can illuminate us
help us as we go through the grieving
process and oh yeah some brand new
titles for the new year here they are
this is the Harland I wear
sit down strap in and tighten your
diaper cover baby you were about to go
down the Heartland highway didn't
bargain for this oh yeah baby please
don't stop this is the Harlan Highway I
hate yeah well that's the way it goes
what do you say we get down
[Music]
20:17 can you believe it oh my god OMG
OMG oh my god OMG and this crazy 2017
we're coming up on 2020 pretty soon Wow
I wonder what kind of new weird freaky
stuff allowed this year outside of the
new title sequence how about that do you
like the new Harland Highway intro title
sequence I hope so I think it's kind of
fun always get excited when we need to
new titles ice I saved it just for the
new year
thought it would be great to spring it
on you guys the first first podcast of
the year just uh you know spice things
up a little yeah uh happy new year we're
gonna have fun this year it's gonna be a
crazy nutty year we have a new president
we have a new a new world we have new
things happening we have new threats we
have new good things we have new bad
things we have new unexpected things
things we don't even know are coming
maybe they find life on another planet
this year maybe you know somebody goes
to war that we didn't expect to go to
war maybe somebody does something crazy
I mean of course people are gonna be
born and people are gonna die and oh
it's kind of daunting but it's fun it's
what makes life exciting right and what
about you my faithful pavement pounders
have you got plans for this year I hope
so I'm going to encourage you right out
of the gate right out of the gate I'm
gonna say to you set some goals set some
positive ambitions here's what I want
you to do cuz here's what I'm doing okay
here's your homework first first day of
the year your homework I want you to
make a list not a grocery list not a
laundry list I want you to make a list
of accomplishments that's right they
don't they can be as big or as small as
you want it they could be cleaning out
the garage it could be getting a new job
it could be writing a novel
it could be finishing a marathon but I
want you to write a list it has to be
minimum of three things minimum of three
maximum of six or you can go as maximum
as maximum as you want but a minimum of
three things I want you to write it down
and with a sharpie I want it to be big
and bold and in-your-face
I want to write 1.2.3.4 letters I will
do this all right I want you to write
one marathon two novel three build a
barn whatever your ambitions are and I
want you to tape it right on your fridge
rate smack dab on your fridge right in
the middle so every time you open that
fridge there it adds staring you right
in the eye and you may think I'm not
gonna do that why would I do that my
fridge is gonna look crummy it's gonna
mess up my beautiful stainless steel
fridge well I don't care I want to see
you guys do some stuff this year not
that you don't but I want you to I want
you to make some definitive choices this
year I want you to I want you to push
yourselves I want you to be proud of
yourself at the end of the year I want I
want you to wanting to put down three
big goals for yourself and hopefully you
get all three but even if you
accomplished one well then that's
something good and make it something big
something out of the box don't don't you
know don't make well I'll clean out the
garage know that that doesn't push you
that's not pushing you mentally
that's not pushing you physically that's
not pushing you spiritually I want you
to do something that that's gonna take
some work some efforts of some some
given it I need you to put the pedal to
the metal and I I want you to and I'm
saying this for you cuz I want you guys
to accomplish something something you've
been putting off something that's
important to you something that can help
define your life your meaning your
existence of being on planet Earth your
legacy your future your past whatever it
is does that sound fair and I'm gonna do
it - I'm gonna do it - believe me I'm
gonna do it I'm probably gonna put six
down because I'm an overachiever but I'm
definitely gonna put three and for those
of you to think you're slouches and you
don't well I don't have any ideas in my
head I mean what would I want to do
possible if you don't have something
think of something all right
yes I'm scolding you that dig deep go
back to when you were a young kid in
high school when you when you were 18
and you said you know someday I'm going
to write a novel someday I'm going to
write a play someday I'm going to sing a
song someday I'm gonna be a track and
field star someday well that someday is
now and I want you to find it and I want
you to accomplish it and I want you to
feel good about it and be proud of it
and well the world beats a path to your
doorstep or only if you do it just for
you and you're the only one that knows
at least at the end of 2017 you can go
man I feel good oh I did it I finally
did it
oh you can do a Charles Nelson Reilly
cheer now does that sound cool there you
go little little pep talk to start the
Irate at the beginning rate at the very
beginning and then at the end of the
year I hope I hope all you pavement
pounders will follow me in and say
you know what Holland I don't really
like you I don't like your podcast but
that thing you said at the beginning of
the it got me thinking and I think
you're a douchebag but I did it anyways
and you know what I did it I wrote my
first novel or whatever it was I went to
Europe and I took pictures of of statues
that I've always wanted to do that and
I'm not looking for any thanks at the
end of the year I'm looking just for you
to get to thank yourself for doing it we
only live once and the clock is always
ticking and you don't want to be laying
on your deathbed and holding your kids
hand and saying you know what Johnny I
always wished I had gone to Italy and
learned how to go to cooking school
Johnny that's something I never did but
I want you to do it for me too right
time waits for no man or woman so do it
put three things on a list and sharpie
write up on your fridge this year all of
you not suddenly the one I see you I
hear the ones rolling their eyes I hear
the one well I don't even have a fridge
well go out and buy one I want all of
you all of each and every one of you not
one of you goes through the cracks on
this podcast all of you this is the year
to get motivated and then do those
things or at least one of them and at
the end of the year I better hear from
some of you I wanna hear I wanna I want
to hear that you took that sharpie and
fell that beautiful black ink and put a
line right through some of the items on
your list you just that squeaking ink
you crossed out you crossed out the to
do things on your big list oh that's
gonna feel good and it could be
something insurmountable it could seem
huge it could seem daunting at the
beginning of the year but you can do it
I believe in you I believe in
you please believe in you to everyone
listening we're we're a group here
everyone listening we all believe in
each other we're in this together we're
a group we're a group of overachievers
this year for once come on gang
right good there I got that out of my
system now let's kick the year off with
some good good old comedy how about a
good old crank call I always have fun
when I make crank calls dissection
let's start the year sexy Roger chew it
up we're crank calling a sex shop come
on how are you today I'm fine hey do you
guys carry the the artificial vaginas
down there we do great great what's the
widest one you have oh you know we have
so many different ones you know it's
hard to say it's just we got quite a bit
of choices for those cuz I'm you know I
don't want to get too personal but I'm
wide I'm very like I'm not that long but
I'm really wide and I don't want to get
my meat into one and rip it you know
what I mean okay like so many different
ones that stretches with the material
whatever so yeah I mean you have to come
check since there's such a variety of
them well let me ask you this might cut
to the chase like if do you have a
tennis ball there like could you shove a
tennis ball into one and just let me
know if it doesn't rip and then that's
kind of my wheelhouse okay call me back
within probably thirty minutes I can
probably look around and see what I
couldn't oh great you'd be able to shove
a tennis ball in a vagina for me find
something like oh we don't have a tennis
ball around here but I mean I could kind
of at least get an idea maybe a stapler
I don't know what yet what do you have
there you could shove in you know dude I
gotta say I would have to take time they
really look around to see what size
which size of your shoes maybe
my shoes a ten-and-a-half maybe that
could you shove one of your shoes in the
verge on track
Rock I say right now I'm real busy and
I'm the only one here at the moment so
but I did if I get a mic at the moment
I'll feel like a fine okay I'll let you
I just thought what kind of shoe is it
and then I'll let you go I just wondered
Oh another leather dress shoe and just
stuff it in the vagina great great okay
half an hour that's fine all right thank
you so much Oh God
good lord a leather shoe I should have
called them back and made them follow
through oh my goodness what a fun way to
start the year with that one right good
night Nellie frittata oh and speaking of
singers boy uh you know as you know we
lost George Michael the the singer who
used to phone the show a number of times
a year and we had a bit of a contentious
relationship you know he was a little
yeah I had a personality let's let's say
that much you guys heard him he was
sometimes hard to deal with I had to
talk to a Malati I think he got lonely
and he liked to phone the podcast and
boy oh boy we're all sad about his
passing but we wanted to get feedback
from someone in the music world and we
were actually able to track down another
George this is remember Boy George from
The Culture Club so Rach do we have him
on the line Roger yeah we got Boy George
from The Culture Club on the line and
let's let's take a call and just talk to
him about the passing of Boy George
put him through here we go this this
could be emotional put them through ROG
[Music]
hello Boy George are you there sir yes
is that you how you hello boy how are
you okay George so listen okay listen
let's let's talk about the passing of
someone I'm sure you knew from the
industry someone you were close to
George Michael I mean how is the music
world reacting to his sudden death dying
at the age of 53
[Music]
Christmas was at dawn ways worked over
Appleseed records here in the United
Kingdom we both at different times we've
done outcomes together with Tom and they
called me up and I was just devastated
you know I was I was sitting in the
kitchen having a cup of tea and it was
just heartbreaking really because you
know he's only 53 years old and he
carries about a command in the situate
it was such a brave man talent talented
man well you know George you said
everything right it's boring George all
right it's not just George it's not just
boys
it's Boy George I seem to remember you
did this a lot George Michael I'm sorry
I did my apologies I just I I get I just
used to say
one name and I'm not used to saying two
names together hello you know it's boy
all right I got it I'm sorry boy I'm
sorry I said I'm sorry boy okay I got it
got it I'm sorry I'm just if you can
give me a minute to catch my breath here
I'm still reeling over the death of
George Michael I'm still in shock I'm
still grieving
[Music]
I mean we've lost two pioneers is a
wonderful talented man yeah I mean have
you have you got any feedback from any
other musicians that you work with or
you know oh my god I you know it was a
rough year it was 2016 we lost David
Bowie we lost Prince we lost George
Michael I mean it's just just a really
painful year for musicians dying isn't
that right boy boy I'm sorry what did I
say destroyed your craving
I'm not good I'm not going to take any
more of your phone calls I am I'm
terribly sorry I'm so distracted right
now I just I will not play this game I
would love it if you were if you know
maybe you can pick up where George
Michael left off you can call the show
you could you know be be our eyes and
ears to the music industry in the United
Kingdom hello no no I I'm sorry
once my head clears once I'm through the
window of this grieving process I I will
be fine there'll be no miscommunication
between us so we would love it if I used
are you clean by the way cuz I know you
went through your own round of heroin
addiction and drinking and no I'm just
asking because it's it's ironic that
George Michael kind of went down a
similar path and he was well a lot of
similarities actually between you and
and George Michael and you even share
part of the same name George hello no I
please I'm grieving
Boy George there is that was a huge in
in America as well yes I'm sure you are
George whoa well Roger I meant to say
Boy George Oh God oh you know maybe we
did maybe we don't want to open this can
of worms maybe is he gone
Oh God you know maybe maybe it's for the
better that Ethan he hung off good lord
he's gone okay but but maybe we don't
want another guy with two names you know
why can't we just have like Neil Young
or or Bruce Springsteen maybe I'm not
good with with remembering the double
name the George Michael the Boy George
George of the jungle Curious George I'm
not good with the double George's so
maybe let's make that a one off call and
we won't we won't start up again with a
new British singing celebrity that
that's it's probably just gonna lead to
problems so that was that was a one-off
call and I'm glad we were able to get a
perspective from Boy George on George
Michael George on George action well I
don't mean it like that but just and you
know well we'll leave it there thank you
for hooking us up Roger and let's move
on let's switch gears to something more
fun you know hey Roger how about this
Roger
time to time I go into Rogers booth and
in November it was was it November
October it was your birthday and I
remember Roger played me this thing this
morning when I walked in I guess I guess
one time when I was in Rogers control
room there you know we have people
calling the show and somebody called the
show to talk to Roger and Roger got just
for fun had me pick it up and I just
messed with the guy calling in to Rogers
control booth can we play that that
phone call Roger I think that'll be a
fun thing for the listeners to hear
remember that when when I started
messing with that guy yeah cool okay
here we go this is me and Rogers control
booth messing with someone calling in to
ask him a question about the podcast
here we go hello hello this is Dave I'm
filling in today how are you pretty good
for the last two or three days to wish
him happy birthday yesterday was the
tenth is birthday talking like two
months ago the tenth I told him mine was
the 20th of October how about last night
what do you think at 11:00 p.m. 11:00
11:00 p.m. on the 11th day of the 11th
month oh yeah you know what Rogers not
here anymore he got a job over at the
Chips Ahoy
play you know doing Chips Ahoy cookies
yeah yeah he got a job over at Chips
Ahoy he's the I guess they had an
opening for the chip counter no no he's
come off the belt they have to make sure
I think they put 14 chocolate chips in
each cookie and he's the new chip
counter I guess no he has to check all
of them just count the chips and you
just wanted to change it's hard
sometimes when roger was there because
he has to do bits and pieces and stuff
like that well speaking of bits and
pieces over a Chips Ahoy he's looking
for all those chocolate bits and pieces
I know we were all surprised but he said
yeah you know Roger he's up
math guy he loves numbers he loves
counting and I'm not sixteen nine ones
in a row that's nine one let me ask you
have any chocolate chip cookies in the
house you got anything with like chips
or anything in the house we can count
honey you got you got any mint chocolate
chip ice cream in the house what do you
got you got anything with something in
it we need Thin Mints all right here's
what I want you to do can you put one on
the table just put one on the table my
12-foot measuring tape to see how thick
it is
just put it put it on the table where
are you in the kitchen at the coffee
table all right you put it down flat
yeah now curl your fists off and just
give it one smash just one just just pop
it can you do that for me yeah okay give
it one smash cement coming through the
cooking bleeding out okay did you smash
it yet yeah I smashed mostly to my left
is where the mix oh through the right
didn't get smashes evenly all right
here's what I want you to do with I want
you to count the pieces now that you've
smashed it how many pieces did it come
out seven dude not good news you're
gonna be hit by a truck tomorrow
all right well listen I gotta get going
I gotta go to the bathroom I just ate a
whole Jimmy John's submarine sandwich
sideways and my bowels are about to blow
up like a killer whale at a [ __ ]
mafia festival and chips we'll talk to
you soon
what's your name Tommy tingle buns we'll
see you later bro all right brother take
care that guy man I can't believe he
smashed a thin mint on not his coffee
table for me such dedication such as
such a Oh so that was fun I snuck into
Rogers soundbooth and maybe we'll do
that again maybe maybe we'll do another
one of those in the in the future in the
days to come but I think that's a much
more positive upbeat way to end the
first show of the year we're not dealing
with you know Boyd George being angry at
us and so on and so forth right so once
again Happy New Year everybody
and I hope you have a great year and
don't forget to put that that list up on
your fridge I'm holding you accountable
and I want to mean I want to make sure
you guys get something really cool done
this year that you've always wanted to
get done okay
and it'll be awesome so uh let's have a
great year 2017 let's let's kick it off
with a few announcements here my first
stand-up comedy gigs of the year are
coming up always exciting to do that
first show of the year I'll be in West
Palm Beach Florida at the improv on a
beautiful city with a beautiful Club
West Palm Beach
that'll be January 19th to the 22nd okay
January 19th to the 22nd West Palm Beach
and then the following weekend I shoot
across back to the west coast to Tacoma
Washington
the Tacoma comedy club that's January 26
to the 28th a great great comedy club if
you're on the west coast and then Johnny
good nights in North Carolina
February 9th to the 12th look at that
I'm just going from coast to coast to
coast what's the matter with me
at least I'm getting some airline miles
right good night so there you go check
out Harlan Williams calm while you're
there you can contact me on the contact
list or you can call me three to three
seven three nine forty three thirty and
leave a voicemail if you'd rather do
that three two three seven three nine
forty three thirty and
you know leave me your thoughts and it's
gonna be a fun year I've a lot of fun
things happening this year I'm hoping to
put out a new comedy special that's
gonna surprise a lot of you it's gonna
be another very unusual comedy special
my new TV show is set to launch it looks
like it might it might have gotten moved
up to April once I have a firm
confirmation date I'm gonna fill you
guys in on the show this show is gonna
play in a hundred and forty five a
hundred and fifty countries all over the
world you kidding me
this is gonna be a crazy show that's
seen everywhere on the planet I'm very
excited about it I know I haven't told
you much about it but I will fill you in
more as we get closer to the date and
all kinds of good things and one of one
of my personal things you know I started
a science fiction novel since we're
talking about getting things done the
top of my to-do list for 2017 as I
started a science fiction novel years
ago and I've been working on it here and
there I think I'm up to like 250 pages
or something ridiculous and I haven't
finished it and I want to finish it this
year that's part of my mission this year
is to finish that darn novel so uh
that's a big ambitious thing I'm putting
on my to-do list right on my fridge so
let's see if you guys can match it with
something bigging ambitious for you and
that's it Happy New Year everybody I
know I've said it a million times but I
really mean it I want you to have a
great year and we're gonna have lots of
fun here at the Harland Highway podcast
lots of fun guests lots of comedy
lots of commentary lots of
thought-provoking stuff and that's it
for today first show a 2017
thanks for being here tell your friends
and until next time chicken chow mein
[Music]
I love you if you pulled me into it and
I don't go to pop playing it